lish alicia is with us in charlotte hi
Alicia how are you hi
great thank you thank you guys for
taking my call I may be super quick your
phone your phone is coming and going if
you can speak directly into the
microphone I'll be able to hear you
better
can you hear me better yes ma'am thank
you awesome
so my husband and I we've been married
for about half years now and we
officially started your plan July of
last year my husband technically wanted
to do something similar three years
before that but here we are today so my
question is we're going back and forth
because we just bought a townhome
January of 2017 so this is our second
year of having it and we're trying to
figure out if the house is the problem
or not you live in yes we do live in it
how much is your payment our payment is
1456 what's your household take-home pay
a month take home is approximately 6,000
okay no you're right on track we tell
people not to have a payment more than
1/4 of their take-home pay and that's
right where you are house is not your
property
yeah house is not your problem eating
out is your problem so we did do the
budget and we've cut our grocery bill
honestly from 700 to about 400 crazy but
we have a daycare bill as well at about
eleven hundred a month that's not fair
crying that's not your problem how much
dad have you gotten not counting the
town home about a hundred on what a
credit card credit cards about eighteen
six on that eighteen thousand six
hundred twenty thousand dollar car and
sixty-three incident loan okay your
strain is that pile that pile is the
string as you Whittle that pile down
your strain is going to start to go away
the daycare is not the problem it's the
credit cards in the car payment
if you took those two out of your budget
you could breathe right now
yeah so yeah so getting very very
intense very very intentional very very
focused on that debt snowball listing
your debts smallest to largest
everything but the house and attacking
that smallest debt have you cut up your
credit cards yet yeah we still use them
we got you cut them a lot yet no it's
not cut them yeah tonight you got to
clean this mess up right you got you're
gonna have to do some things that are
dramatically different because you've
been dramatically running in the wrong
direction and the hundred thousand
dollar that's where your pain point is
and what's your help you and women I
know your household income your
household incomes approaching a hundred
so you're it's gonna take you three
years to clean up this mess of beans and
rice rice and beans and no vacations you
don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant less your work in their
lifestyle on your every dollar budget
and that's where you guys have got to do
you got to have no life and clean this
up as you do that you're gonna start to
feel the relief the financial peace two
words that don't go together like
Airlines service this is the Dave Ramsey
show